trovo tutti benvenuti solito ottimo
challenge che vi è stata consigliata da
voi quindi grazie mille per averla
consigliata ci avete letto perché non
fate la challenge in cui dovete fare lo
slime senza fare rumore è per
controllare per tracciare il suono e
sentire quanto è alto quanto basta
utilizzeremo una app quindi la vedrete
qua qua ho qua qua non appena inizia
così vedrete appunto chi sta facendo più
rumore chi fa piu casino anche se io già
un'idea se lotto no vitale ogni cosa che
fa unico la nostra muove fa casino per
può far tutto si sbatte ai muri si
sbatte i tavoli
quindi questo dovresti passare al mio
dove altri mio cappello magico cappello
magico perché non tornano tumori se
diventate uno chef penso che non
funzionerà mar nero o il suo cappello
magico perché niente funziona per separi
sempre che arrivino a quindi mi
raccomando alla fine del video dovrete
votare servizio sul rosa in base a
quanti rumori abbiamo fatto e in base a
chi è stato più silenzioso sicuramente
sarà una sala ance difficile ma
divertente quindi mettetevi comodi
patatine buon corse casa sarà quello che
è un bel haj che se volete altre
challenge slime consigliate sulle cure
nei commenti iniziamo la vita come già
sto volando da ridere perché sicuro che
farò
[Musica]
no
[Applauso]
[Musica]
oddio allora come state per stanziarli
per te devi fare tutto il casino che non
hai fatto
mamma mia quanto mi hai fatto arrabbiare
e o tu mi fa trovare una via vai in
realtà e guarda come un sito bellissimo
enne è stato gianni lannes bellissima
fine ho cercato di mischiare talmente
dame ei colori di fatto che possono fare
il verde grigio topo grigia però è
uscito argento vendola argento
metallizzato e grigio topo le macchine
vogliamo veramente parlare del colore
del pulvirenti che rumori mr e grigio
topo il tuo che bello la vita i pochi
che vi ho fatto che fare ad artico
votate qua che ha vinto se ho vinto io
odio vinto vitale lasciatesi nei
commenti saini stampa del momento che mi
ha fatto più ridere così cieli
riguardiamo per favore notare le
differenze ho capito che sarà pochettino
più prossima impauriti e permetterle se
tutto incollato alla mano ciò che
tiziano se questo verde con tutti i
brillantini neri sotto la valanga state
votate la società il top fatica perché
altre sale se volete vedere se volete
che ne facciamo un altro che dovevo
stare in silenzio consigliati cosa
dovremmo fare perché non solo divertiti
un sacco non vediamo l'ora infatti di
rivedere questo video quattro volte e
ora vi lasciamo con quattro case lire su
cui cliccare per vedere inoltre altri
video e l'ostetricia nel design
sto school azionando lo slime adesso
deve stare cliccate sulla cartella che
preferite buona visione
ciao